Guten Morgen andre.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Weißt du in weniger als sieben Jahren hat dieser Podcast mehr erreicht als fast jeder andere Podcast in der Geschichte des Internets.
Also mit der Reaktion habe ich jetzt nicht gerechnet aber das ist auch okay.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 269 vom 27 September 2018 live aus der Metaebene mit ohne Linus aber dafür mit André André Meister Hallo.
Ja Andreas sehr schön dass du es hast einrichten können.
Ich muss ja Ines hat mich zwangsverpflichtet wenn er irgendwo im Urlaub ist.
Sei es ihm gegönnt.
Da müssen ja alle antreten genau ihm sei es gegönnt ja wir haben so ein wenig gerätselt.
Dobermann in eigentlich diese Woche sprechen muss weil die Nachrichtenlage ist dünn oder wenig überraschend.
Vieles ist schon besprochen worden und ich meine dieser Maßen Fallout ich weiß nicht ob man da überhaupt noch viel zu sagen kann also in der vorläufige Sende der Geschichte ist man hat sich jetzt noch mal zusammengeräumt und die zumindest ein Staatssekretär veraltet und irgendwo so als Abteilungsleiter für irgendwas
für bleistiftanspitzer Bestellungen oder sowas reingeholt wahrscheinlich Dritter im hintergrund trotzdem noch irgendwie seine Dinger.
Aber immerhin hat sie Bundesregierung geschafft sich auf allen Ebenen zu bekleckern wie es mir irgendwie möglich waren jetzt stehen und wir alle blöd da.
Was für ein clusterfuck und dann gleich noch der nächste Klasse folgt mit der Verschiebung in der Unionsfraktion aber wir haben beschlossen dass wir darüber hängig überhaupt.
Ja man kann auch nicht viel zu sagen und das ist irgendwo auch alles im Fluss und keine Ahnung ob wir jetzt den Sturz der Regierung vor sich vor und haben oder ob das einfach alles erfolgreich ausgesessen wird auf jeden Fall ist es für uns.
Alles kein Thema nutzen wir lieber die Zeit auf andere Dinge zu schauen.
Ich dachte mir es wäre vielleicht mal ganz interessant mal darauf zu schauen was ja eigentlich bei netzpolitik.org.
So treibt jetzt war ja gerade die Konferenz die ja dann immer irgendwie auch den Geburtstag mit feiert und das ist ja dann schon der 14,
jetzt nicht so ein rundes Ding wo man wieder Gedeih Halligalli macht aber trotzdem immer wieder man ganz gute Gelegenheiten bisschen innezuhalten.
Wie lange bist du jetzt schon dabei.
Ich habe vor 10 Jahren mein Praktikum gemacht
und da so ein bisschen Dinge will Vorratsdatenspeicherung geschrieben zwischen meinem Bachelor und Master an der Uni meine feste Stelle habe ich seit Januar 2012 das sind jetzt auch schon sechseinhalb Jahre.
Aber wir feiern eigentlich schon 10 Jahre an den Meister.
Ja wenn man wenn man möchte 14 Jahre Netzpolitik 10 Jahre André Linus war ja zwischendurch auch mal kurz da.
Wir feiern eigentlich ich sehe die Konferenz unsere Ausrede überhaupt mit unserem ganzen Umfeld zu feiern dann im Arm die Konferenz ist ja nur der Grund Woche damit wir die Leute auch alleine fliegen können tagsüber feiern ist sowieso ab und zu mal ganz gut angesichts der Welt Lage.
Ja das ist auf jeden Fall angemessen wie war denn das als du dahin gekommen bist wie groß musste man sich den Apparaten vorstellen dass der den Konzern.
Es gab keinen Apparaten das gab keinen Konzern das ganze Netzpolitik ist ja so eine.
Markus milch mir verzeihen Vorleistungspflicht ist seine Perspektive ein bisschen anders aber.
Das ist ja so aus dem Markus arbeitet in dieser Firma newthinking zu organisch hervor gewachsen die hatten da irgendwie paar Leute oder Dutzend Leute sonderwette
Bude mit was man halt damals so gemacht hat anfangen dann Urlaub Internetseiten CMS
Mail und so für Leute erhaltene Internet Netz Agent Agentur oder so hieß das früher mit dem Fokus auf viel Open Source.
Und Markus hat von Anfang an irgendwie dieses Blog nebenbei betrieben das sieht ja ganz am Anfang backpacking the world politics das war so irgendwie travel,
mit Münch mit meiner Isomatte
words samedov information society nach Thun nach Thun thun ist Fahrer oder nach Brüssel zu irgendwelchen Dingen Softwarepatente werden die ganzen Lobbyisten irgendwie alles profimäßig organisiert habe,
es war ja schon sehr persönlich am Anfang isarova hier das neue Ubuntu Update ist da und so.
Aber mit der Zeit hat er mehr und mehr Zeit genommen sich unter anderem während der Arbeitszeit aber eigentlich eher so twentyforseven mit den Themen zu.
Beschäftigen und daneben auch in dieses Blog zu vermelden und ja.
Gerade mal.
Praktisch.
Ich hatte ja ich hatte auch ich hatte tatsächlich vor 10 Jahren.
Und zwar so ziemlich genau 13.08 2018 habe ich ein CARE mit ihm gemacht über ist wichtiges Wissen über die man das erste oder das.
War das über netzpolitik.org oder war das dieser CAE der auch worauf Falk mit da war.
Nee nee das war nur mit ihm und ich glaube da ging das Anwesen nicht drin aber ich habe auch schon.
Vorher eine der allerersten Folgen 2005 habe ich schon mal mit ihm gemacht da ging es konkrete um data retention Urheber Urheberrecht.
Was ich gar nicht mehr da gab's auch schon netzpolitik.org also ich habe das was ich zweimal so von Anfang an mit.
Reeses data retention Urheberrecht ja genau.
General CARS ja sowieso schon lange vom Krieg erzählt und irgendwie seitdem es Podcast gibt und auch die Historie davor noch mal aufgerollt im Podcast Format war ja klar dass er e007.
Kommt man ist das lange her.
Dö dö dö dö dö dö dö.
Genau und irgendwie markus hat das von den einem nebenbei Projekt immer mehr zu das ist seine eigentliche Arbeit.
Durchgesetzt in diesem newthinking.
Was ich nie so wirklich unmittelbar monetäre rentiert hat für die Firma aber unter anderem dadurch dass er ein Haufen Leute kannte und auch selber so präsent war in Medien,
hat das denn mit dazufügen
dazu geführt dass sowas wie die Republica überhaupt in der Form entstehen konnte das war ja sehr geprägt von den Themen auf Netzpolitik und den ganzen Leuten mit dner
da schon großen Netzwerk hattet ihr denn mit Einführung konnte das Wald gemeinsam mit Spreeblick gehören auch ihren Teil dazu beigetragen du finking auch und so also,
viele Leute daran mit.
Kritik zwei Blocks die so ein bisschen den den Samen gelegt haben um eine der größten Konferenzen in Europa.
Werne Blogger Konferenz Mannheim anfangen.
Wird es immer noch so genannt.
Klassentreffen der Bloggerszene.
Zwerge dauert zwischendurch was auf meinem Blogger Messe das fand ich auch ganz geile ja ja das wird auch langsam.
Gerne mögen den Jahr was dann aus so irgendwie Zwitter irgendwas na ja wie auch immer jedenfalls Dinge wie die Republica hättest und in das Netzpolitik nicht gegeben.
Aber das war immer noch an eigentlich nebenbei es gibt keine Werbung auf dem Blog und Markus wurde eigentlich nicht dafür bezahlt das zu tun.
Ich habe ab und zu mal ein praktikabler das war das lief organisatorisch alles über new thinking,
und irgendwann ich kann dann anfangen 20.12 dazu auf einer halben Stelle weil ich die Inhalte den Kontinent gut von wie gesagt hatte schonmal Praktikum machen dann auch nach meinem Praktikum weiter geschrieben über Zensursula und was dann alles da war
einfach nur weil ich Markus Kante unten im Block Account hatte jetzt ohne großartig formale Struktur von Redaktionen irgendein Thema vorher absprechen sondern einfach irgendwie ins,
WordPress rotzen und auf publish drücken so lief das die längste Zeit Linus hatte ja dann 20.11 auch eine halbe Stelle.
Hat dann aufgehört und ich habe dann quasi eine Stelle bekommen weil quasi noch vor mir angestellt auf man nach Meer.
Habe ich ihn ja raus gekauft.
Der Amazon Wunschliste,
und dann waren erst Linus und dann ich quasi überhaupt erstmal eine zweite festere Person neben Markus und irgendwann 20,
12 13 oder so mich an nachdem ich angefangen habe und wie der Praktikumsvertrag bei mir fängt gegen auch im Arbeitsvertrag dann bei mir fängt gegen bekommen haben gemerkt müssen wir das eigentlich alles über die new thinking Firma laufen lassen,
gebe es nicht auch irgendwie eine Möglichkeit das irgendwie raus zu lösen und auf eigenständige Füße zu stellen.
Und dann.
Hatten wir gar keinen Masterplan sondern nur die Idee ja wir können ja einfach mal eine IBAN oder nicht Spendenmöglichkeit auf die Seite schreiben mal gucken was reinkommt auch
bisschen auf dich gezielt hier was du mit der Metaebene machst ist ja auch so erstmal machen und dann sagen auch übrigens wenn ihr mögt was wenn es euch gefällt was ihr machen wenn ihr das supporten wollt dann ist
tierspenden Option in IBAN der Bitcoin gab's damals noch nicht aber Efeublätter oder was auch immer das Mittelalter gabs erscheint nicht,
habe das bei dir abgeguckt auch einfach mal ein Spendenkonto hingeschrieben und Flum Konto gründen zu können wollten wir das aber nicht auf unsere natürlichen Personen machen sondern haben wir 8 Uhr okay dann könnten wir halt irgend so ein Verein.
Ja dann auch gleich noch irgendwie gemeinnützig ist,
einfach nur Kontonummer auf die Webseite schreiben zu können aber auf einmal hatten in den Vereinen und dann hatten wir quasi auch ne.
Wie heißt das so schön juristische Personen.
Na typisch deutsche Geschichte.
Schöne deutsche Bürokratie Wörter.
Unsere PAP an sich immer mehr der Organisation weg von dem juffing King hin zu diesem gemeinnützigen Verein die Reinstoffe das Konto gegründet hat.
Geschoben und jetzt mittlerweile sind wir 15 Angestellte alle haben Verträge bei dem gemeinnützigen Verein komplette Finanzierung läuft über den Verein
14 Finanzierung ist fast ausschließlich von freiwilligen Spenden und Spenden finanziert und es gibt noch so ein paar legacy
Details zu newthinking wie das die um widerstehen es noch machen oder so weil das alles irgendwie technisch aus der war gleich nur so bekommt und,
dass wir unter Mitarbeit newthinking sind dass wir quasi auf der Büro Etage immer noch Sinn noch im mit ein paar Mal umgezogen sind worauf Republica.
Wahr oder bzw bis in paar Tagen ist die Republica auch um weil immer was Eigenes braucht genau und.
Irgendwann kam Anna dazu ich glaube als ich das erste mal reisen gegangen binden fürs Winter nicht ausgehalten habe wir haben ja sowieso meistens und prakti manchmal auch zwei,
habe ich ja auch mal angefangen viele Leute bei uns haben als prakti eingefangen und dann als ich ein halbes Jahr nach Südostasien bin habe
sie sich diese Anna biselli die ich von der Freedom Note 4 in Brüssel bekannte von Praktikum behoben ist und ach du bist das ja du würdest ziemlich gut zu dem Laden passen
reicht doch mal was eine als keine Antwort bekommen da müssen wir noch mal Leute treten
die Mail auch zu beantworten aber hat ein Praktikum gemacht und ein für die ersten drei Monate die ich weg war und dann hat sich wieder kam hatte sie dann quasi auch so eine halbe Stelle weil das irgendwie ganz gut funktioniert hat.
Also nach und nach,
sind wir purple gewachsen also dann kam irgendwie Constanze kommen dazu Thomas kommen dazu das war dann auch die Größe von Landesverrat vor drei Jahren da wollen wir dann irgendwie zu fünft oder so im Büro plus im prakti.
Und seitdem,
ist ja noch mal gewachsen irgendwie Stefanie wie unsere ganze irgendwie Orga schmeißt unsere Büro der Markus Reuter kam dazu.
Jetzt sage ich jemand vergessen weil das wäre natürlich peinlich Ingo kam von der digigas schreibt auch seitdem.
Ziemlich konsistent.
Chris köver ist jetzt die neueste Mitarbeiterinnen soweit ich weiß was du kriegst und Alex kamen I am Alex genau was war alles in der Zeit wo,
ist mal wieder weg war genau Alexander fanta österreichische.
Und dann kriegst Chöre die irgendwie das müsste immer gesehen mitgegründet hat und dann lange bei wired Deutschland gemacht hat gewirkt hat ist jetzt auch bei uns.
Also sind in letzter Zeit schon mal noch.
Ordentlich gewachsen und jetzt haben wir auch gleich einen interessanten Schritt gewagt alex ist jetzt erstmal nach Brüssel gegangen,
um aus Brüssel zu berichten denn schielen tun wir da drauf schon ewig irgendwie ein paar von uns sind,
ziemlich nah oder sogar in die Symmetrie European digitalriver hier im Podcast auch oft behandelt so viele Dinge passieren.
Also Carsten Fiedler Thomas Lohninger vor allem ne eine besondere Nähe Warna mitarbeiten.
Kinox.to Kirsten und Thomas bloggen ja sowohl für Netzpolitik ab und zu als auch sind hier wackelmann ihr Christen war auch schon mal da.
Sind noch hier gestern mein jo hatte dir ja auch schon gehabt und so der Block ist nicht für uns aber mit dem ganzen E3 Team sind wir in relativ nein Austausch.
Aber auch Ralf unsere Büro Jan Philipp und Julia Reda
also also Brüssel ist verdammt wichtig das merkt man ja auch an den Themen aber bisher gibt es irgendwie,
bitte keine europäische Öffentlichkeit gibt kein gemeinsames Esperanto oder irgend so eine Sprache heißt die ganze Berichterstattungen läuft eh unter immer nur in nationalen Medien und dann immer nur aus der Perspektive einer nationalen Perspektive,
und das hat auch niemand großartig Ressourcen deswegen fordern die ganz großen Medien das Mittag und der Tagesschau steht dann irgendwie vor dem rad Gipfel oder so und hat deine Noten für wie spät jetzt wieder geworden ist.
Irgendwelchen Themen aber das neue Richtlinien gibt bitte in irgendeinem Bereich der viele Leute relativ,
intensiv betrifft so Urheberrecht oder alle unsere Themen das findet ja in den großen Medien nicht statt den könnte man das ja gar nicht als Zielgruppe erklären sogar irgendwie auf spenden würden das solche Dinge nicht geklickt
erst wenn es dann zu spät würde und das in Deutschland umgesetzt werden muss,
dann ist auf einmal das Geschrei groß mit was haben die in Brüssel schon wieder gemacht oder so aber nee das ist wird ja jahrelang vorbereitet.
Und wir versuchen schon,
lange relativ früh darauf zu blicken ist mein die Anfangsphasen von Netzpolitik waren ja auch Softwarepatente auf EU-Ebene dann Vorratsdatenspeicherung von EU-Ebene über a
da Akte haben wir uns irgendwie die Finger wund geschrieben e dass irgendjemand interessiert hat und dann irgendwann ganz man den magischen Moment wo das groß geworden ist und so.
Deswegen als um noch besser.
Ziemlich früh und nicht erst wenn es zuspät ist aus diesem Brussel berichten zu können.
Am allerletzten und nicht alles nicht so wirklich hingeschickt er ist auch der freiwillig dahin geschickt habe mit Alex und Brüssel und ist mal gucken ob das Experiment funktioniert auch so im.
Redaktionsalltag mit irgendwie jeden Montag macht man halt irgendeine Sitzung nicht dass wir auf Meetings stehen oder so aber mal kurz die Woche abklären ist schon ganz wichtig und machen wir schalten den jetzt digital dazu und so den ganzen Prozesse haben wir eh nicht.
Also professionalisiert wegen den großen Häusern mit irgendwie hierarchischer Strukturen CVD und einzelnen Ressorts und.
Ich wollte gerade fragen wie wie.
IBAN und Edith wohnen.
Wie sehe wie wie viel ist denn noch Block und wie viel ist denn schon journalistische Arbeit man als Journalisten Fett hat er nun schon ausreichend geadelt.
Bis auf die f**** hat vor kurzen irgendwie zogen den ganzen Maßen Drama auch nicht Landesverrat noch mal erwähnt und difaz hat,
immer noch nicht geschafft uns als Journalisten zu bezeichnen sondern ihrem immer noch das Wort Blogger verwendet.
Aber da sind auch die eins das einzige Medium in ganz Deutschland was ich irgendwie diese Blöße gibt also tatsächlich sind wir ne ja.
Wenn man sich mal die Blogger anschaut hören ihren eigenen Reihen hatten zum ist bis vor kurzem noch irgendwann.
Trauma das waren ja auch keine Journalisten sondern nur Blogger meinst du.
Ja irgendwas so.
So bisschen albern.
Yatas also tatsächlich kommen wir ja auch so aus dem Netz,
so flache Hierarchie und eben videophone gemeint habe einfach mal einen WordPress aufsetzen was reinschreiben published Rücken und auch irgendwie
mal Markus und das gelbe Knöpfe drücken einfach mal gucken wie Medien so funktionieren und wie Öffentlichkeit so funktionieren.
Und die wenigsten von uns ich glaube Thomas und Christa eine ok und Alex haben tatsächlich,
eine förmliche journalistisch Ausbildung und alle anderen haben irgendwie einfach nur
Dinge für die sich interessieren und können das dann halt runterschreiben aber ist jetzt schon wissen ist ja auch dass du die Kunden schreiben aber,
müssen dann erstmal Themen finden über die sie berichten können deswegen viele auch relativ Generisch Meldungen machen können oder so.
Jeder schreibt dann auch im Wesentlichen über die Sachen wo erfährt das eigene Interesse liegt.
Nenne mir ich wollte gerne rausfinden so so sind wir gewachsen und irgendwie mit,
23 auch fünf Leuten in einem Raum wo man irgendwie,
auf dem kurzen Dienstweg einfach was durch den Raum rufen absprechen kann oder auch im Jabber natürlich kommunizieren wir gern 4 digital.
Oder auch beim gemeinsamen Mittagessen oder so bitte sicherstellen dass man auf einer Wellenlänge bleibt,
das hat die längste Zeit ziemlich gut funktioniert aber mittlerweile sind wir 15 Leute und irgendwie auf also nicht alle Vollzeit sondern
was kann ich mit vielen neuen oder 10 oder so Vollzeitstellen verteilt also auch nicht jeder immer da da gibt's da so Verschiebungen und,
das ist nicht so langsam die Frage dass wir mehr Struktur brauchen und eben bestimmte Themen Verantwortlichkeiten oder so aber das haben wir ja nicht
gelernt da kommen wir nicht her das erarbeiten wir uns,
quasi nebenbei in unserem Alltag die bisher sind die Themen Zuständigkeiten eher so wie du hast ja schon immer Thema X bearbeitet also wenn was neues zu dem Thema reinkommen dann kriegt das natürlich die Person die das schon immer gemacht hat was irgendwie.
10 in in 20 Jahren dann schreibst du für Trojaner weekly ein Unternehmen der netzpolitik.org Gruppe.
Manja und und Vorratsdatenspeicherung hoffentlich haben wir das dann nicht immer noch genau,
never wenn jetzt irgendwas zu e-privacy ist dann kriegt das erstmal irgendwo oder so oder Urheberrecht dann fragen wir den Leonard ob er Zeit hat und ob das interessant ist wenn er keine Zeit dann müssen wir gucken ob wir das selber.
Netzausbau Thomas Rudel C.
Genau genau.
Und gerade als Leonard erwähnt habe ich meine Haare noch ein paar Studie sich nicht genannt haben Marie die Fallen bekannt von dem Polizeigesetz and Simon,
der auch schon eine ganze Weile dabei ist genau 3 hätte vor 3 Jahren Praktikant angefangen und da ist wohl die geblieben.
Und Leon der glaube ich im letzten Jahr oder so dazu kommen.
Und so dynamische Verteilung von von Themen passiert
bei uns also er somit was einen interessiert woran man gut ist aber auch schon mal hiermit das ist jetzt wichtig aber niemand hat unmittelbar Zeit
wie wäre es denn mit hat einer irgendwie der Studis oder der Praxis oder von außen unserem Netzwerk drumrum.
Genauer gibt auch noch mal wieder Gäste Beiträge ist zitterer.
Wobei das Beiträge irgendwie ich habe den Eindruck dass wir mehr auf Leute zugehen und Anfragen als andersrum es Leute bei uns an
antipodes Beiträge die wir angeboten bekommen sind nicht immer die ganz qualitativ hochwertigsten kommt auch vor aber wie das im Internet so ist wäre schon meine öffentliche Kontaktadresse gelesen hat,
die diverseste Zuschriften rein.
Wie,
sind denn bis bisschen so Diva oder wie ist deine Wahrnehmung wie die Wahrnehmung von netzpolitik.org in der Öffentlichkeit ist so über die Zeit.
Also ich meine wir haben das ja schon so wird angelteig immer so dieses als Blogger bezeichnet werden immer so implizites Diminutiv in der Hinterhand aber,
ist ja jetzt nicht so das nicht verschiedene Berichte,
und natürlich dann auch dieser ganze Landesverrat Skandal nicht auch eine ganze Menge Welle gemacht hat wie würdest du denn sagen hat sich so die Wahrnehmung der Öffentlichkeit und die Bedeutung des Outlets verändert.
Sehr gute Frage was kann ich aber ich dadrauf sonst spezifische Antwort hab denn ich würde mal die These Wagen wenn man jetzt eine x-beliebige Fußgängerzone geht und fragt was denn,
zufällige Personen von Netzpolitik halten
dann halt dann lautet die Antwort wahrscheinlich immer noch wahrscheinlich nicht außer man hat dann irgendwie mal jemand vorbei wahrscheinlich erinnern sich Leute noch an Landesverrat oder so oder man hat dann irgendwann oder jemanden die Themen interessieren da kommt das dann
schon da.
Ich meine dass das jetzt keine Bild-Zeitung Bekanntschaft ist klar ne aber überhaupt erstmal mit wem wen erreicht man und wie.
Wir reichen extrem viele andere Journalisten.
Siehe auch diese diese ganze Republica Konferenz da irgendwie alles was was mit Medien macht kommt ja da auf diese Republica zusamstraße ganz wie viele Besucher die mittlerweile Tage haben 12000,
auch irgendwie so fast Kongress Größe also echt Wahnsinn.
Das rennen geht weiter Wasser.
Beide haben mal mit 200 Leuten angefangen Erste Republik A300 Leute das war wirklich Blogger Klassen.
Das auch.
Also extrem viele andere Medien Journalisten auch Leute die Kommunikation machen PR und so gerade von den Firmen und auch Politikern die wir berichten und so was sind die,
Leute in der Politik auch und in den Unternehmen die für politische Kommunikation zuständig sehen ob das jetzt Referenten im Bundestag oder irgend im Landtag sind,
oder auch irgendwie die Presseleute von Telekom und Co die haben natürlich ziemlich genaues Auge auf uns in den Themenbereichen.
Und.
Auch die Medienlandschaft guckt die auf uns wirken kriegen sie auch mit wenn irgendwie Artikel die zufällig vormittags bei uns sind dann zufällig nachmittags irgendwo anders ähnlich aufgefasst worden sind wir Träume auch von Anfang an,
eben durch unseren eigenen Blick auf Zusammenhänge durch unsere eigenen connections ist unsere 1,
eine Einordnung was wir wichtig finden ja auch ein Agenda-Setting was an dankbarerweise auch von anderen aufgegriffen wird.
Und wir sind auch Ansprechpartner für Medien dass sowas relativ oft bekommen und wo aber nicht alle unbedingt so mega Lust drauf haben deswegen vor allem Markus und manchmal so ein bisschen Constanze und themenbezogen dann einzelne Leute machen ist.
Anderen Experte für andere Journalisten sein irgendwas ich selber Interviews machen irgendwie auf den Markus in der Tagesschau ist oder so
das ist ja jetzt nicht der ureigene schon alles muss dass wir hinter der Kamera stehen und andere Leute interviewen sondern eben dadurch dass wir die Expertise bei uns aufgebaut haben dem durchdringenden Kontakte haben Dinge auch versuchen verständlich zu machen für ein größeres Publikum
dieses Wissen was bei uns in der Originalform steht dann noch mal O-Ton kompatibel für Tagesschau zu machen oder so.
Und an der Stelle an der Stelle wird ja auch einmal interessant
wie eigentlich die Wahrnehmung und das Selbstverständnis ist ne weil man kann ja sagen ok.
Das Roulette journalistisches Selbstverständnis ist man berichtet über alles und wie neutral und Schiller die Dinge wie sie sind sorgfältig,
ist am so mein Geschmack ja ganz anders aufgestellt sagt wir haben hier irgendwie eine klare Meinung
sollen wir haben Prinzip der auch unsere eigene Agenda sagst du ja auch ne wir machen auch Agenda-Setting also muss es ja auch keine Agenda geben
und wenn man dann sozusagen als Experte irgendwo dazu geladen wird dann eben auch schnell so diesen Vorwurf na ja ihr seid ja eigentlich auch nur eine Lobbyorganisation.
Ja ich glaube das hat sich auch so ein bisschen gefangen und eingeordnet in den letzten Jahren.
Ich betrachte sowieso seit Anfang an als überkommene abgrenzungs Rituale der wird euch schon alliston,
ich habe irgendwie Sozialwissenschaften studiert der allererste Vorlesung war es gibt keine Objektivität.
Jeder Mensch hat eine eigene Prägung und eine eigene Perspektive und eigene Erfahrungen und alles ist subjektiv die Frage ist.
Also ich schon allein welche Themen berichtet man überhaupt irgendwelche Interviewpartner nehmen welche Stimmung als jede jedes Medium ich meine kann ja auch sagen dass die Katze ihr links ist und bringe eher konservativ Rechtsaußen.
Ist ja nicht so dass ich nicht in beiden Journalismus gemacht wird aber da gibt es nicht die eine unmittelbare objektive Wahrheit sonst gäbe es nur ein Medium was alles gleich klingen alles ist subjektiv nur wir geben es wenigstens zu wir machen das Transparent,
wir schreiben auf unsere Seite was unsere Positionen und unsere Meinungen sind die anderen tun so als ob sie die objektive Wahrheit gefressen haben,
und dann irgendwie nur weil sie zwei Seiten anhören dann irgendwie neutral werden niemand ist neutral aber wir wir machen das wenigstens,
ganz explizit so aber die letzten Jahre haben ja schon,
bisschen weggeführt von dem Dogma mach dich nicht kannst mach dich mit keiner Sache gemein selbst mit einer guten irgendwie so ein komischer deutscher Journalisten,
die genannten Schule gelernt bekommen sondern wir leben ja immer mehr Journalismus mit Halterung und so ist ja irgendwie gerade irgendwo besser das machen wir schon immer,
und wir finden das auch richtig.
Ja wenn die Haltung stimmt.
Es gibt ja da auch Haltungen ich meine Flat nicht unbedingt so einnehmen.
Ja aber das machen wir ja dann nächste Zidan konnten wir dann auch mal oder so aber klar auch die Bild-Zeitung macht schon alles muss mit Haltung nur halt der Anhaltung halten wir für verachtenswert.
Und hast du das Gefühl dass schon irgendwas erreicht wurden.
Mit was der Weltrevolution.
Möhre mit dem Projekt hier mit dem netzpolitik.org irgendwas besser geworden oder nur weniger schläft.
Weißt du wo ich bin jetzt jetzt fragst du den Beruf Pessimisten
wenn ich irgendwie vorhin gesagt habe mein erstes Posting vor 10 Jahren war über die Vorratsdatenspeicherung und dann irgendwie das Thema ist immer noch da wir haben vorne Büro überlässt gesprochen was du mit Markus besprochen hast das ist immer noch da,
natürlich haben wir was erreicht auch die ganze netcommunity und die kritische Öffentlichkeit
wir haben Themen gesetzt wir haben unsere eigenen Perspektiven eingebracht wir hatten auch wohnst schon dass die Vorratsdatenspeicherung abgeschossen wurde das irgendwie
das Netzsperren Gesetz sind so so la zurückgenommen wurde das irgendwie die Wahlcomputer in Deutschland eingestampft wurden oder so wir hatten natürlich immer mal wieder gewinnen wir sind ja,
relativ gut aufgestellt in Deutschland gucken ja auch viele andere Länder,
auf uns ich spreche jetzt mal so von der digital community als als Ansicht von der Netzpolitik sich ja als ein Teil davon fühlt.
Auch Netzpolitik hat schon Dinge reicht irgendwie haben so eine komische Sammlungen Urkunden an der Wand hängen von dem irgendwie Land der Ideen und Landesverrat nur zwei Sims irgendwie Grimme Online Award und Journalistenpreis des
Bundestag ist unsere außen förmliche Ziele der herkömmlicher Institutionen haben wir schon paar mit eingesammelt.
Und wir haben natürlich auch so ein bisschen die Medienlandschaft mitgeprägt schon allein dass man.
Sich komplett von Spenden finanzieren kann und dass man wie du erst macht und dann sag wenn es euch gefallen hat dann refinanziert das doch bitte dass man irgendwie
original Dokumente veröffentlichen kann dass man irgendwie sich Innenausschuss setzen kann und einfach mit schreiben kann und so oder sind ja irgendwie Konzepte wo wir rumexperimentiert haben.
Seinen eigenen privat Polizist mit dem Rücken hat.
Aber viel experimentiert,
manches hat funktioniert manches andere natürlich auch nicht aber wir wachsen und dann auch die Medienöffentlichkeit da draußen also
es gibt irgendwie dem Podcast
Untersuchungsausschuss macht weiter zum neuen Breitscheidplatz andere schon Listen am angefangen auch Dokumente in möglichst voll online zu stellen oder so Finanzierungsmodelle wären auch von allen anderen
mit genauer auch durch Crowdsourcing heißt das jetzt neu deutsch.
Crowdfunding ja stimmt Crowdsourcing ist ja auch schon wieder zehn Jahre alt.
Ja ich meine manchmal brauchen die Dinger halt auch ein paar Jahre bis es bis man wirklich die Auswirkungen davon merkt na und dass das dass ich dann Dinge auf einmal auch
verfestigt haben die für einen zwischendurch zwar irgendwie normal waren aber movis Gefühl hat Ruppert das wird ja alles gar nicht,
aber dann gibt's mal wieder so einen kritischen Punkt wo dann eben diese Sachen auf einmal so eine ganz eigene Normalität ausstrahlen und dann die Basis für alle weiteren Entscheidungen sind
also insofern nur noch sagen weil das jetzt nicht alles.
Aber.
Magst du gern bei dir zu sein und Fragen auch umzudrehen jetzt hast du mich an nach der Innenperspektive gefragt was ist denn was ist denn deine Perspektive auf die 14 Jahre haben Netzpolitik jetzt gefeiert
wie siehst wie sich das Ding nicht nur gewandelt sondern auch was es irgendwie erreicht hat.
Also meiner Wahrnehmung ist es so nett für die Korg ist auf jeden Fall so eine so eine journalistische Marke und dieses was du meintest mit Mann Mann
man gibt ja
Nachrichten auch eine Relevanz finde ich hat es halt so eine Rolle wie auch heiße schon über Jahre vorher gehabt hat so wenn es bei netzpolitik.org aufgegriffen wird dann ist es auf jeden Fall schon mal irgendwie ein Ding,
so und wenn es nicht aufgegriffen wird dann warst vielleicht auch nichts also ist auf jeden Fall schon mal so eine Instanz die wahrgenommen wird mit OK.
DAP da geschieht jetzt auch was und nicht ich bin hier irgend einem falschen Twitter Feeds irgendwie wieder ja weil man hat ja auch dieses Problem,
der der Überprüfung jeder von uns hat zumal und ein Scheiß retweetet oder ist er auf irgendwas oder hat auch irgendwas als nicht relevant eingestuft im ersten slide ausweiten Moment
wo dann ebenso eine Einordnung einfach Bitternote rot und natürlich müssen sich da
entsprechende Instanzen herausarbeiten und ich sehe ganz klar dass dass das bei netzpolitik.org so ist ich finde auch.
Der Grad an Professionalisierung so nimm im guten Wortsinne
finde ich finde ich super also das mal wirklich so viele Leute da in Lohn und Brot bekommen sicherlich nicht reich macht aber zumindest irgendwie die Möglichkeit bietet sich da entsprechend auszuleben und zu verwirklichen
das schon eine Leistung soll ich mal sowas mal ich habe z.b. nicht und Rippen und die Republica sehe ich eben auch,
ja schon gesagt hast als ein Spin-Off aus aus dieser Grundhaltung die ist,
auch sehr
erfolgreich geworden definiert Dinge auch noch mal auf eine ganz andere Art und Weise in der Öffentlichkeit geht halt sehr viel mehr über den Pop was sie hätte ich auch so diese pressante Vermischung von
mit Spreeblick ist sowieso ein bisschen so ein Sonett Pop und Netzpolitik solarin in einem dass das ist schon echt eine ulkige Kombination die aber an sich ganz erfolgreich war und glaube dass das,
auch mehr Nachhall hat als uns vielleicht manchmal klar es weil sich da einfach immer mal wieder so.
Neue Generationen bilden irgendwann triffst du mal wieder so auf Leute
die sind in diesem ganzen Strudel mit 14 Jahren geraten und da war das irgendwie alles groß und wahnsinnig und die Küche dann fünf Jahre vor sich hin und kommen dann auf ihre geile Idee und
naxan einfach das in all dem was sie dann tun von diesem ganzen kulturellen
der breiten Bewegung die für Sie denn Normalität dargestellt hat so tief geprägt sind dass da Dinge einfach selbstverständlich sind wo das vorher immer so ein täglicher Kampf war
und ja das ist das ist meine Wahrnehmung dieses Projekt und ich find's gerade gut dass ich das jetzt auch europäisiert.
Wichtig weil ich habe auch immer wieder gemerkt wie in dieser ganzen Debatte und so ein bisschen.
Außer die steigungsfähigkeit fehlt weil man eben sieht ok in Europa
verlagert sich eben viel nach Brüssel bzw werden diese Themen und müssen diese Thema auch in zunehmendem Maße länderübergreifendes goutiert werden und das findet natürlich einfach durch diese Sprachbarriere nicht so ohne weiteres statt
klar wir haben hier so ein bisschen unseren Austausch mit Österreich und ab und zu Sieghart mal auch die Schweiz rein natürlich jetzt nicht in so ein EU context ist aber natürlich auch in einem europäischen da
können wir dann vielleicht auch was leisten aber schon so der Sprung nach Polen Tschechien schon Frankreich ist,
irgendwo weit entfernt und da ist dann vielleicht.
Brüssel schon auch ein wenig die Zukunft so einfach weil da sich die Leute den des auf wie auf eine bestimmte Art und Weise gelinkt
weil sie sich damit an den anderen treffen das Brüssel ist ja so ein bisschen sodass sowie Berlin für Deutschland ist
ich muss alle hingehen hin und bisschen frustriert sind und und und neue Grenzen ganz Erfahrung machen wollen kann man eigentlich jetzt in Brüssel das da ausgeben habe ich bei allen gespürt die da zumindest auch mal für ein halbes Jahr waren.
Dieses als extrem belebend angesehen haben weil da eben all die anderen Leute die auch so aus Politik schon ja aber irgendwo komme ich hier in meinem eigenen Land auch nicht so richtig voran
die treffen dort eben die ganzen anderen aktiven und stinkt da kann sich noch so einiges groß entwickeln dass ein bisschen meine Wahrnehmung.
Ich habe das auch noch Potenzial weil selbst wenn wir jetzt deutschsprachige aus Brüssel berichten ist das ja wieder nur für eine teilöffentlichkeit.
Irgendwie einen es mit gemeinsame Sprache gibt's ja nicht aber Englisch ist ja einer der dominanten Sprachmemo aber da wird es auch schon Bündnispolitik in Europa,
also dann gibt es irgendwie edry und Fader
national organisation gegen auch auf Englisch machen und dann fahren in UK mal gucken ob die noch Europa sind aber
als Medium z.b. findet der relativ wenig statt der gibt ja nur irgendwie Politiker und your active und dann die ganzen großen nationalen Häuser die dann irgendeinen Korrespondenten haben oder so.
Mal gucken wir versuchen unseren.
Europa muss Europa muspop werden.
So auf allen Ebenen,
politischer Pop und warum Pop also klar will haben jetzt gerade so eine Phase der totalen Europa Apathie hinter uns aber man sieht auch schon das eigentlich der ganze.
Backlash der jetzt so einsetzt mit den Rechtspopulisten und merkwürdigen Vormarsch von so Vollidioten haben Österreich und Ungarn Polen eine Zither Schweden jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen und UK dass das aber auch eine entsprechende Gegenbewegung
nährt die meiner Meinung nach auch irgendwann wieder die Sache anschieben wird man mag das ja schon das gerade auch in der brexit
vielleicht überhaupt das allererste Mal in diesem
Land in UK auch so eine europäische Bewegung gestartet hat die ist so vorher gar nicht gab ja und in den Locken dran denke ich mal kann sich das sehr positiv auswirken weil ich denke das wird schon wieder,
aber ich bin ja auch Berufs Optimist.
Ein Schritt zurück aber dann doch gleich wieder zwei nach vorn.
So läuft es gut.
Bleibe noch mal kurz bei netzpolitik.org und zwar vielleicht ein kurzer Rückblick auf die Konferenz die letzte Woche stattgefunden hat.
Die Ladin 2018.
Er hat wirklich gesagt das ist Netzpolitik.
Na ja aber dann aber so komisch ist rufe auch komische Abkürzung dafür find ich find das gut der neue Standard im Konferenzbereich,
Bayern bisschen anders man das Ding ist vor vier Jahren gestartet.
5 Jahren wo fünf Jahren gestartet zum 10 Geburtstag und war ja erstmal nur so ein kleines ja wieder so ein Klassentreffen Dundee,
der der des politischen Korrespondenten und hatte eben genau wie I Republica auch so dieses Heim Liegegefühl mit 80 sind ja mal alle zusammen wie schön diesmal muss ich sagen was das erste Mal,
ziemlich Eindruck davon gehabt habe ich ganz am Anfang schon die Frage in den Publikumsbereich in dem großen Saal in der Volksbühne Berlin spannt ist ja Stadt naja wer von euch vielen feiern wir was die 150 Leute oder sowas da weil insgesamt zumindest in dem Moment vielleicht nicht alles komplett besetzt
Wer ist denn hier das erste mal da und gefühlt wann unten 90% der Leute das erste Mal da.
Da waren doch ich alle ziemlich überrascht von dem Feedback und als ich so bisschen durch die Leute durchgegangen habe ich auch die ganze Zeit nur hier wo sind denn jetzt die Leute die letzte Mal die ganze Zeit getroffen habe was ist denn da bitte passiert.
Hätte man auch da aber das hat sich halt verteilt also wie du gesagt hast haben wir ich weiß gar nicht wie groß die erste Konferenz war.
Die war hier oben im Pfefferberg auch Berlin Prenzlauer Berg weiß gar nicht wann das 100-150 Leute oder so ich weiß dass wir letztes Jahr irgendwie.
300 Leute plusminus dass es 350 sein da hatten im Kosmos ist das den glaube ich,
und ich glaube so ungefähr 300 und dieses Mal war so irgendwie 700 oder mehr als 757 Leute was ja schon mal irgendwie mehr als eine Verdoppelung ist,
fand ich auch krass schön dass es funktioniert habe ich meine wir hätten da irgendwie auch uns blamieren und irgendwie.
Das sind die Hose gehen können aber schön dass nicht nur Netzpolitik als Marke und als Block und als Arbeit sondern eben auch dieses Angebot einer eintägigen Konferenz,
einem Arbeitstag in Berlin war eine Freitag muss man auch erstmal sich frei nehmen können kann nicht jeder.
Dass das so cool angenommen wird,
und mich hat auch überrascht als Geraldine bei opening gefragt hat für wen ist es denn I und tatsächlich fast jeder Hand ging nach oben Schock Grad wo kommen die ganzen Leute her also.
Es waren jetzt
viele neue Gesichter da es waren aber auch die üblichen Verdächtigen ist sowas ja nicht ist muss noch mal durch die speakerin und Speaker scrollen und es war immer jemand kaum läuft mal x 10m findet man jemand damit ach du auch hier lange nicht gesehen und wie läuft's bei dir so,
natürlich das war immer noch kein irgendwie 15.000 Leute Kongress aber tatsächlich ist ist gewachsen.
Ja da ist irgendwas passiert genau das zeigt was dass das zeigt dass da eine andere Wahrnehmung ist.
Das zeigt dass die Themen präsent sind und angenommen werden nun wichtig sind und allgemein die Netzpolitik Perspektive auf viele Dinge relevant ist.
Irrelevant irgendwie Leute fliegen ein Haus nicht nur Österreich und,
Schweiz hatten wir Leute sondern irgendwie aus der ganzen Republik es war gar nicht mal nur Berliner Publikum.
War jeden Fall mal wieder eine sehr schöne Konferenz fand ich einen Tag letzten Freitag also jetzt irgendwie.
6 Tage her und wir haben ja das erste Mal auch die das prestigeträchtige neue Location Volksbühne,
in Berlin-Mitte bespielt was diesmal zum erstmal drei Floors hatte also gibt's den irgendwie grandiosen Rhys-Davies Lünen.
Radiobühne den Grünen und den Roten Salon.
Genau die Hauptbühne ist irgendwie das große Theatersaal auch ja sehr ist geschichtsträchtig.
Dann dann auch wer Kultursenator aus Berlin ins Schwärmen der in dem einem wichtigen Kulturhaus des Landes.
Bürgermeister der Stadt haben zugesagt.
Ja warum wohl.
Bürgermeisterin war dann.
Krank geworden leider genau jetzt mit Leon über Smart Cities sprechen sollen und daneben grünen Roten Salon wo noch mal jeweils du kennst das besser jetzt noch 150 Leute reinpassen.
Noch mehr 200 vielleicht mit einer Bestuhlung.
Ungefähr so.
Untis liefen 3
Tracks parallel quasi solifemar große Vorträge in der Hauptbühne und dann noch ein kleinerer oder
teilweise auch manche DAV Vorträge in den kleinen Bühnen waren so voll die hätten auch in die große Bühne gepasst aber das hinterher ist man immer schlauer
und dann irgendwie die Lage der Nation hatten live
Podcast gemacht dann ist ein aluhut bastelworkshop irgendwie in dem Polizeigesetz Vernetzungstreffen und so also auch relativ viel außerhalb dieser drei offiziellen Vortragsräume ist ja auch
komme aus dem Netz und aus Community und so ist ja auch nicht alles nur Frontalunterricht sondern viel auch im Powerman vernetzen
Leuten bisschen eigenen Raum geben und so ich glaube das hat recht gut funktioniert.
Wobei,
das ist wahrscheinlich dann auch eine Stelle wo der Event jetzt nachlegen muss es wirkte dann doch etwas in diesen Vorräumen ein bisschen unter benutzt so,
klar da waren ein paar interessante Dinge und schön dass man da mal so ein bisschen rumbasteln kann aber irgendwo hätte es nach nach nach sehr viel mehr.
Zusatz Bespaßung zum Nachgang fällt mir das gerade so ein
geschrieben da ist also auf jeden Fall die Möglichkeit das an dem,
Orthanc noch ein bisschen illustrato machen vielleicht nicht nur so an den Vorträgen zu machen muss auch mal aufpassen man tendiert ja dann dazu
immer alles vollzustopfen Oris haben wir drei Tracks und der Tag ist kurz und ne viel viel viel aber viel ist nicht unbedingt immer mehr also das man auch gut guckt dass man
die Pausen nutzt dass man den Leuten die Möglichkeit gibt da die Begegnung auszuleben.
Hasen für die Lehren die man immer dann irgendwann zieht da wird sich auch beim Kongress in diesem Jahr entsprechend was verändern.
Ja nee aber insgesamt kann man sagen war das ganz gut wenn wir vielleicht noch auf ein paar talks hinweisen ist alles aufgezeichnet worden das Team vom Club war dann tue ich da hat alles aufgezeichnet entsprechend sind die Aufzeichnung alle auf Media ccc.de.
Wie immer grandios also die Livestream in allen erdenklichen Farben und Formen dann haben sie uns auch noch irgendwie mit Beamer Problemen den Arsch gerettet nebenbei,
und irgendwie die ganzen recording ist freie Lizenz sofort online noch irgendwie die Party vorbei war und so also ganz ganz große Leistung wie immer von dem Wok was die mittlerweile für einen,
einen geübten Workflow haben und auch an
ganze Jahr über Veranstaltungen Weg rocken das ist ja nicht irgendwie nur die großen Club Veranstaltungs und daneben auch so Dinge immer weiter den Umfeld wie unsere Veranstaltung sehr sehr großes Kino.
Matlab mehr im Schnitt schon mehr als eine Veranstaltung pro Woche also es ist mega.
Erste völlig völlig gerade und und auch da werden Leute nicht wirklich viel bezahlt da gibt es mal hier irgendwas von Entwicklungen oder so aber alles ehrenamtlich.
Crazy.
Super also papryki.
Das sind jetzt wir hatten vorhin gezählt oder 28 recordings von der das ist Netzpolitik Konferenz in Audio und Video also kommt fällt auch aus dem Podcatcher wie sich das halt so gehört.
Da gibt's Podcast feeds wurden.
Restaurant ganz oben rechts ist so ein Feed Icon und.
Ada da muss er noch mal.
Hast du dann auch MP3 in das kannst du dann auch abonnieren und das ist ich habe das in meinem Podcatcher.
Okay dann muss er mal ein Podcast podlove subscribe Button rein ja.
Das Kaisers kannst du mit dem Bock hast kannst du mit dem Wok die Maus machen hast du noch nie genutzt nee das eine echt coole Funktionen ich hör die.
Erstmal mir war nicht klar dass das wieder drin war das früher mal rausgeflogen.
City recordings als Audio beim durch die Straße laufen so Carl sind quasi Podcast Format.
Nee ist total super.
Und beide müssen wir es natürlich die stehendes ist 6 Tage danach oder bzw 5 Tage später und wir haben noch nicht megafil gehört bei mir liegt das alles auf dem die weiß aber das kommt dann jetzt alles nach und nach.
Was war denn dein Highlight im.
Also ich habe natürlich auch nicht alles gesehen ich fand,
Julia Reda mal wieder sehr straight und überzeugend,
das ist für Sie natürlich jetzt alles gerade extrem frustrierend muss man dazu sagen diese rüber Rechtsgeschichte wie sie gelaufen ist MDR ja ausführlich behandelt in letzten Sendung das war natürlich im Prinzip totale Katastrophe und Wort nicht das was sie
wollte und dementsprechend man auch wenn man sich so mit ihr unterhielt,
also does not amused nichtsdestotrotz hat sie die Faust wieder hochgehalten und darauf hingewiesen dass ja hier auch noch nicht alles am Ende ist es gibt ja immer noch die Möglichkeit das Gesamtpaket abzulehnen das wär dann zwar auch schade aber immerhin statement.
Ein schöner Überblick.
Also die Zusammenfassung von ihr sie litt leider besonders unter den Beamer Problematiken die da am Anfang des Tages noch existierten von daher gab es da wenig slides Gedöns aber ist am Ende nicht ganz so entscheiden,
dann habe ich den Vortrag von Erich Möchel gesehen.
Ja ich möchte doch ganz kurz selber noch nicht im Podcast bei euch ne deswegen sag mal einen Satz dazu zu ihm.
Ja also Erich ist ja aus Österreich die man wenn man ihnen sprechen hört auch unschwer Märkte kommt David ich mit einem.
Stringenten Dialekt an Start
Erich ist so ein bisschen auch so nationalistisches Urgesteine nicht politischen Bereich also der hat schon gefühlt schon immer dieses bespielt er war halt lange Zeit bei.
Futurezone in als Teil des ORF am Start bis dann versuchen ja irgendwie aufgelöst wurde dann ist er auch weitergezogen war aber eigentlich immer die sichtbare Stimme,
im also Österreich ohnehin aber auch im deutschsprachigen Raum,
was so den Überblick über Geheimdienste und deren Aktivitäten und Überwachungsstaat und so weiter also gefühlt auch immer derzeit mindestens 5 Jahre voraus.
Der hat schon Netzpolitik gemacht da war noch gar nicht so dran zu denken dass irgendwann mal netzpolitik.org gibt.
Genau also ganz wichtige Person extrem cooler Typ noch dazu.
Opa Erich Erzählform cyberwars in den in den Neunzigern.
Also für den war das schon irgendwie alles klar und er hatte auch vom paar Jahren das hat mir glaube ich ja auch mal erwähnt auch diesen schönen eine schöne Recherche zu den Wochenstart ordnen.
Wien.
Österreich gemacht und es kommt immer wieder was geiles bei raus und er kann auch sehr unterhaltsamen vortragen hat er auch wieder gemacht jetzt Kritik in der Ära Cyber 4.0.
Hast das gleich zweimal drei Weiber und 4.0 in einem.
Bisschen ich finde hat ein bisschen weit ausgeholt und hat dann irgendwie hier sehr nerdig vorgetragen was du quasi der Fehler der Amerikaner gewesen ist unter anderem.
Bei den Wahlen und wollten wir Sie sich vor den Russen abends auf dünne Eis führen lassen.
Weil sie eigentlich einen viel zu technischen Blick auf cybersicherheit gehabt haben und es immer nur so im Kontext von.
Sicherheitslücken im Netzwerkbereich jetzt gesehen haben aber letzten ist von den Russen auf der Informationsebene auf dem Layer 8 quasi gehackt wurden und das hat er ganz schön.
Ja schön präsentiert und zeigt auch mal wieder dass er dass er sehr auf der Metaebene auch.
Was war noch Jens kugeltiere war da der eine der war ja hier nicht zu Gast sondern nur Moritz Jens ist auch.
Long time activist auch aus den Neunzigern CCC schon ewig verbandelt hab vor ein paar Monaten meinen ersten Artikel auf Netzpolitik vor 10 Jahren noch mal verfüttert mit dem alten Layout über die Vorratsdatenspeicherung aber ein einziger Kommentar der war von Jens
tube Ziel ein sogenannter Pingback wir hin dass noch was sagt um einem anderen Block Bescheid zu sagen dass man nicht in einem eigenen Blog auf.
Und Jens war ja ist es auch Tausendsassa macht viele verschiedene Dinge unter anderem ist ja in den Verein zwiebelfreunde wurde mit durchsucht seine Wohnung in Jena wurde durchsucht.
Wegen diesem Augsburg for krawalltouristen Blog.
Aus verschieden Umständen war er da gar nicht zu Hause sondern nur seine Frau und Familie deswegen auch der Titel Schatz wir haben Polizei in der Wohnung.
Er hatte noch mal ein Abriss gegeben was genau dort passiert ist und unmittelbar danach haben wir denn du musst mal ganz kurz runterscrollen dann noch eine Präsentation von Anwalt Ulrich Kerner genau,
über IP durchsuchen kann man angeschlossen der noch mal die do's and don'ts eben erklärt hat wie man sich.
Ja was tun wenn's brennt wie man sich verhält in Vorbereitungen und im Ernstfall wenn es soweit ist können ja nicht alle den.
Auch sehr klassischen Udo Vetter Vortrag sie haben das Recht zu schweigen von vor das ist auch schon wieder acht Jahre her oder im Kopf haben deswegen ist ganz gut das ab und zu mal zu erneuern.
Unsere Auswahl der Torx ist natürlich nur subjektiv und nicht vollständig, hier auf dem Roque ist doch nach Klick sortiert wieder Nummer ganz nach oben was ist denn ganz weit ausge die glaube ich am selber,
Werbung für sich gemacht wollte Christel hat mir auch aus Wien die österreichische Fraktion ist derzeit relativ stark 45.
Über digitale Profile über überwachungs Kapitalismus also der hat sich guckt sich ja schon seit Ewigkeiten online Trek gegen und Werbemarkt und diese
live Auktionen für werbe Ausspielungen auf Webseiten an und so.
War auch alle Fälle viel Inhalt drin Leonardo Buschor natürlich auch wie ein Abriss gemacht über sein,
zdf-fernsehrat in dem man sitzt und wie Creative Commons und öffentlich-rechtliche zusammengehören oder auch nicht das Thema mit dem man den letzten 2-3 Jahren total präsent ist durfte natürlich bei uns nicht fehlen.
Ja diverse Diskussionen,
hast du noch ein Highlight im Madmax und dsgvo das war auch ziemlich cool Tom Hillenbrand Science Fiction Autor der Überblick.
Dürfen.
Das habe ich auch gesehen ja ja ja das war ja erst ja Autor und,
ich fands ganz schön weil er hat im Prinzip mal wieder den Optimismus gepredigt ne also er meinte eben das
wir extrem geprägt sein von dystopischer Science-Fiction und vielleicht in diesem prüfungsmuster eben auch immer alles sehen und immer so Gott die Welt geht unter lalala und hat halt im Prinzip.
Positive Science Fiction Ausblicke gepredigt und dass das doch bitte die Debatten,
mehr beeinflussen sollte.
Mit einer
wunderschönen Überleitung von dem Anfang dass alle seine Seifer irgendwie dystopisch ist und dann aber gemeint hat mehr wenn man jetzt mal zurückblicken hätte wären sie wohl nur zu 84 überleben in 2001 im Weltraum überlegt werden den Atomschlag von Furminator überlebt der war wohl 2008 oder 2009
in oder so also es muss nicht immer ganz so schlimm kommen wir hier in der dystopischen Seife
es gibt ja vielleicht auch Grund für Utopien Science Fiction Utopien gibt nicht ganz so viele aber gerade im
um nicht nur Abwehrkämpfe zuführen sondern eben auch mal positive eigene Entwicklungen Vorstellungen mit den Debatten zu werfen war ganz cool
war auch ganz coole Überblick auch er leidete unter dem Problem das ist ja leider keine slides gab in den drei Vorträgen nichtsdestotrotz sehr unterhaltsamen und
steckte children.
Ja ich war noch bei den Kollegen hier von Lage der Nation die da live aufgedruckt haben hätte möglich mit Logbuch Netzpolitik auch gemacht da hätten wir auch machen können aber,
Linus Meier gar nicht da und daher hat sich das ohnehin erledigt.
Schöner Überblick auch immer wieder von Aram Bartholl your shopping cart is empty
Deichmann ca Eventim gemacht Knie ganz lange halten für einen der tollen digital künstler der einfach immer wieder so einen wunderbaren Blick auf
die Einflüsse von digitalien so auf unser Leben hat und auch die ganze Absurdität auf immer wieder wunderbar auf dem Punkt bringt Salzwasser irgendwelche Leihfahrräder.
Die normalerweise auf der Straße liegen dann ist sein Ausstellungsraum auch einfach auf dem Boden liegen lässt oder dann mit den
Besuchern alle zu so einem absoluten Turm zusammen Trumpf oder so schöne Amazon backen macht wo man dann nicht drauf drückt und irgendwie Hundefutter bestellen sollen so ein Jones Strike auslöst,
immer wieder super Ideen und die hat er dann in 15 Minuten kurz vorgestellt, sich auf jeden Fall mal.
Ist noch viel drin das war jetzt nur nur ein Abriss keine keine keine objektive vollständige Wiedergabe einfach mal durchklicken missgestimmt für jeden und jeder was dabei was interessant ist.
So jetzt war dann doch vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen inhaltlich sein deine dein Schwerpunkt bei netzpolitik.org in letzter Zeit oder überhaupt.
Bist du das Trojaner Wesen aber dazu sagen.
Ja in letzter Zeit seitdem ich irgendwie das letzte mal reisen war habe ich mir mitgenommen dass das.
Extrem wichtig ist finde ich Staatstrojaner und dass das von ja der restlichen Medienlandschaft da draußen nicht annähernd so intensiv verfolgt wird wie,
ich finde das ist angemessen wäre manche ich auch noch jede Menge andere Dinge,
und in dem Laden mit 15 Leuten machen wir ja auch gar nicht nur englische Redaktionsarbeit und schreiben und recherchieren sondern so metaphor.
Aber tatsächlich ja ich will jetzt als letzte Mal hier waren wir auch über Trojaner gesprochen da hätte ich dann irgendwie Part Dokumente aus,
was war das Innenausschuss oder so Protokolle das ist der Bundestag geredet hat
und Diakonen wissen wollten ja 5 welchen Firmen kauft ihr denn jetzt eigentlich ein und die Region gemeint Hallo ganz schlimm alles ganz streng geheim und ja nicht streng geheim aber ist alles,
darf nicht an die Öffentlichkeit das können wir auch nicht mal den Abgeordneten sagen Länder,
in den letzten Jahren also vor allem mit dem wieso Dicker Mensch im Ausschuss gesagt hat aufplatzen des Trojaners 20.11 durch den CCC,
noch mal einen ganz schönen,
Wandel gesehen dass seitdem irgendwie versucht würde noch mal mehr den Deckel drauf zu halten und irgendwie vertraut uns wir machen das schon richtig ja nicht wieder irgendwas falsch machen und die böse geben.
Der Staat möchte Trojaner.
Und möchte sich wenig kontrollieren lassen aber nicht nur die Aufgabe des Parlaments ist es die Regierung zu kontrollieren sondern natürlich auch die Aufgabe der Medien sämtliche anderen Institutionen zu kontrollieren.
Und sowohl was machen in staatliche Institutionen mit Trojanern als auch welche privaten Firmen entwickelnden dieses Zeug oder helfen dabei.
Und was machen die auch in anderen Ländern haben wir auch gerade gesehen finfisher in die Türkei exportiert und so mal abgesehen von so lupenreine Demokratie in wie Bachrain,
Äthiopien und was war das schon alles hatten Ägypten Türkei ist natürlich auch noch mal besonders,
heißt der Zeit Erdogan schon gelandet gehabt er landet jetzt so ziemlich ne.
Es bis bigaia und wie kommt er jetzt an.
Genau und auch wenn ich viele Dinge mache unter anderem recherchiere ich zu was passiert eigentlich im Trojaner Land ich war Sommer auch mal in München und habe mir sowohl.
Die zitis wofür steht Gym zentrale Stelle für IT im Sicherheitsbereich.
Okay irgendwann kann ich das auch noch mal.
Genauer angeguckt also das Haus was sie da haben in ihrem übergangshaus jede Hand bauen gerade in den Neubau und der Bundeswehrgelände der Bundeswehr Uni München.
Und sind noch im Aufbau
mit dem Pressesprecher länger gesprochen was natürlich auch eher so ein Kennenlernen war auf die harten Fragen gibt natürlich keine Antwort von das können wir dürfen wir niemals sagen dass es eingestuft und das sind mit Hoden und so weiter und so fort.
Mamanthethe Webseite.
Ja jetzt sieht es. Bund.de nimm ganz üblichen.
YouTube Kanal und mixing Seite.
Wir suchen Leute heißt das.
Ja Kinderficker entwickelt genau das ist auch das ist auch die Haupt
PR die sie derzeit machen Ihren irgendwie messen rum was war das auf der CeBIT dafür eine Halle hat das letztes mal schon erzählt wo Bundeswehr BFV BND zitis nebeneinander standen und alle
geworben haben bitte Attila kommt zukommen zu uns Kindern bei uns an zu arbeiten die Fischen auch alle im selben Bereich in dem selben Teich.
Genau die Cheat ist ja noch im Aufbau die haben derzeit ich habe jetzt keine harten Zahlen im Kopf aber ich glaube sie haben genehmigt für dieses Jahr 120 Stellen zu besetzen
und davon sind irgendwie 60-80 oder so besetzt so langsam mir.
Sind dann auch mal die vier Abteilungsleiter fest aber es sind noch im wachsenden gibt es habe ich auch letztes Mal erzählt das Bundes.
Kriminalamt hat ja schon irgendwie zwei kleine Staatstrojaner Quellen Durchsuchung entwickelt und finfisher gekauft aber die entwickeln jetzt auch noch mal einen großen Staatstrojaner zur Online-Durchsuchung selber,
und ich frage mich warum macht das nicht die zitis und ich glaube die Antwort ist sie zieht es ist einfach nicht so noch nicht soweit die sind immer noch im Aufbau die brauchen immer noch.
Ja fitte Leute um dann irgendwann mit dem Betrieb anzufangen aber gestern hat der Stefan Krempl aus der.
Quantencomputer strategy das Forschungsministerium irgendwie sind 50 Seiten PDF gezogen adenitis hätte auch gerne in den Quantencomputer um natürlich damit die herkömmliche.
Verschlüsselungsmethoden die wir bisher alles so haben.
Besser angreifen zu können natürlich schon immer so konnten konnten was macht die NSA was macht das die CSU was macht Google auf die gucken würden wahrscheinlich wären es oder vielleicht noch ibm oder so,
oder die Chinesen die ersten die wo irgendwann mal einen.
Für nicht nur wenige spezifische Dinge nutzbar Quantencomputer haben könnten sondern dann auch die generischen vor denen wir uns fürchten müssen jetzt Quantencomputer noch mal ganz kurz erklären.
Naja ich weiß nicht ob ich das erklären kann aber.
Wie wär's mit einem Podcast dazu.
Ja das habe ich auch schon länger mal drüber nachgedacht muss mir noch mal die passende Person zu finden ich meine lange Zeit war das nur so eine Chimera und ist es in gewisser Hinsicht aber immer noch man kann zwar sowas bauen aber noch nicht irgendwie nennenswerten Kapazität
formprinzip verspricht das quantencomputing oder verheißt es vielmehr,
das der Dinge die derzeit nur linear gelöst werden können und das ja bei der Kryptographie immer noch sozusagen das Ding Dinge dauern lange ums komplett ausrechnen,
auf so eine krasse Art und Weise parallelisiert werden können das im Prinzip damit die komplette Crypto fallen könnte
das ist so die Dystopie die einig bei Quantencomputern steht ne und lustigerweise auch die einzige Verheißungen diese Umraum ist ansonsten noch nicht viel Positives gelesen und natürlich ist es angemessen
sich damit zu beschäftigen.
Was sind das eigentlich bedeutet mitdenkt es also es geht ja nicht nur um Verschlüsselung im alten Sinne von Geheimnis sein
Authentifizierungsverfahren alles mögliche ganz grundlegende informatische Konzepte die einfach
den den normalen Lauf von Software hochgradig beeinflussen vieles wäre eben dadurch vollkommen ausgehebelt wenn es gelingen sollte mit Quantencomputer Technologie
hier diese zugrundeliegenden kryptographischen Verfahren auszuleben und von daher,
ist es auch angemessen dass man sich sowas anschaut weil irgendjemand wird er auf jeden Fall dran entwickeln.
Und wer auch immer da die Nase vorn hat hat dann die Nase so weit vorn dass dem Rest die Knie schlackern,
sofern 650 Millionen Euro haben sie mal da drauf geschmissen heißt es hier in den Bericht des jetzt auch nicht jetzt nichts.
Nee aber ich glaube.
Ich habe gestern aber kurz in das PDF reingeguckt ich glaube die 56 € sind nicht von der zitis sondern sind für die ganze Quanten
computer and Strategie des Forschungsministerium oder der Bundesregierung und die zieht es ist ein teil.
Ja okay gut ja nee aber auch das sagt ja schon mal was aus ne also das generell in diesem Bereich sowie Geld fließt halte ich auch für angemessen et cetera.
Wir haben wir haben auch noch derzeit passiert ja viel lassen nicht irgendwie gibt's 567,
total hochrangiges Seibert digital und meistens digital,
Gremien Bundesregierung habt ihr alle schon mal genannt und besprochen und so sondern auch eine neue Agentur Diathek oder so wurde vor ein paar Wochen habt ihr angesprochen ich muss noch mal gucken.
Wofür die dann genau.
Wir haben das angesprochen es nicht dein Ernst.
Nicht ich hoffe ihr ich hoffe ihr habt doch ich glaube das ist diese Agentur auf die sich Verteidigungsministerium und Innenministerium,
geeinigt haben ADEC Agentur für disruptive Innovation im Cyber Bereich oder irgendsowas und VIII war die Verheißung ja die Amis haben eine haben die data,
und die haben uns so coole Dinge gebracht.
Rufe cybersicherheit Yahoo.
Die haben uns so coole Dinge gebracht wie GPS und das Internet und autonome Autos.
Und wie heißt das mausen und Deutschland und Europa hängen irgendwie hinterher und wir müssen jetzt auch irgendwie sprunginnovation machen wenn ein schönes Wort,
das dann natürlich für die gesamte Gesellschaft zu Fortschritt führt aber zufälligerweise auch für die innen und Verteidigungs Behörden amtlich Polizei und Bundeswehr.
Mal ganz abgesehen davon dass es vermessen halt irgendwie deutsche Agentur mit der da war zu,
vergleichen die haben ein Budget also ich muss noch mal nachgucken aber das dürfte umlenken größer sein als das diverse,
kannst du mir nicht ja jeden in Deutschland und bekommt vielleicht an den Bundeshaushalt dran oder so also was die für eine Cola haben,
kein Wunder dass sie auch wirklich dicke Dinge raus fahren können und außerdem,
der was das GPS und sowas an daraus Feld ist auch nur die zivile Variante die eigentliche Entwicklung dort ist auch militärisch.
Wir sind jetzt da drauf gekommen 650 Millionen Euro Bundes Strategie für.
Quantencomputing dann gibt's was war die Summe von dieser Artikel schon wieder ich habe es vergessen aber das waren auch irgendwas mehrere Dutzend Millionen.
Übernimmt Bereich von fünf Jahren die zitis,
hat auch ein Budget was nicht komplett ohne ist also werden diverse Institutionen gesäubert,
mit dir diesen Überblick von Sven Herwig von der Stiftung neue Verantwortung welche deutschen Behörden eigentlich für Cyber zuständig sind er hatte ein Schaubild entworfenes gleich mal raus gucken auf Twitter gucken.
Und es sind dutzende es ist unglaublich dass in Organisationen bei von dem ich noch nie gehört habe obwohl wir uns irgendwie den ganzen Tag als dayjob damit befassen.
Also nicht nur die üblichen BSE und Cyber-Abwehrzentrum und Verteidigungsministerium BV Zufluss zum gleich raus.
Nach der Sendung genau der Zeit passiert viel alle machen,
alle machen selber alle machen es Situationen alle machen digital und es wird Geld drauf geworfen keine Ahnung ob mit Gesamtstrategie jedenfalls diese bei Entwicklungen sie will doch sehr nach
Sicherheitsbehörden aus wir sind drauf gekommen durch die Frage Trojaner und die und ein Teil ist eben
der Titel soll nicht nur Trojaner entwickeln sondern auch Verschlüsselung knacken Big Data Auswertungen machen können und so weiter und sofort alles was irgendwie bei,
Ermittlungen Strafverfolgung aber auch Zoll und Geheimdiensten anfällt und irgendwie technische Probleme ist mit Dinge sind verschlüsselt oder anonymisiert oder so.
Who you gonna call zitis die sollen dabei helfen.
Geh noch mal ganz kurz weg von dem was alles noch so geplant ist und was so kommen soll und weil ich habe auch immer so ein bisschen den Eindruck dass man gerade wenn man immer so auf die Neuigkeiten Pferd reitet,
schnell so ein bisschen Überblick verliert was eigentlich realität ist was ist denn.
Aus deiner Perspektive die gelebte Trojaner Realität.
Müssen deutschsprachigen Raum oder in Deutschland also was findet derzeit statt wird nur viel geredet liegt der Code rum der nicht angefasst wird oder befindet sich irgendwas.
Im Einsatz was ist aus deiner Perspektive so der ist zu.
Leider haben wir keine konkreten Zahlen bei alles ganz streng geheim und das würde ja mit Jungs Erfolg verhindern oder so irgendwann erst in den nächsten Jahren werden wir zahlen bekommen was danach
der Gesetzesänderung letztes Jahr alles so passiert ist also
bis letztes Jahr durfte er theoretisch nur das Bundeskriminalamt und nur zur Verhinderung von Terrorismus Trojaner einsetzen aber mittlerweile dürfen ja alle Polizeibehörden,
auch zur ganz normalen Strafverfolgung für die ganze Katalog an sogenannten schweren Straftaten einsetzen das Reich bisschen zu missbräuchliche Verleitung zur missbräuchlichen Asylantragstellung irgendwie Geldfälschung,
Geldwäsche aber auch betrug Computerbetrug und so wir haben noch keine Zahlen was tatsächlich passiert,
bin da sehr dran es gibt keine Anfragen,
Parlamenten und so aber die Regierung will das nicht so wirklich sagen fakt ist das BKA hat.
Drei Trojaner den selbst entwickelten zur Quellen-TKÜ wo sie angeblich nur laufende Kommunikation überwachen,
und fünf Fische für die große Online-Durchsuchung die einmal alles kann die sind zum Einsatz freigegeben
und damit müssen wir ausgeben nach lange Entwicklungen Langenkamp und langen Freigabeprozess auf der fünf Fische oder so die Behörden haben das und im Zuge der Amtshilfe hilft das BKA auch anderen Behörden wie LKAs oder Zollbehörden oder so
das einzusetzen die Fälle die wir bisher hatten,
waren abgesehen von BMW dann sowieso noch mal ganz eigen ist vor allem Drogen hier dieser Digitas Trojaner 20.11 den der CCC analysiert hat,
der war eingesetzt gegen irgendeinen an ab 1 gegen irgendeinen Bodybuilder der Bezug wie Anabolika aus der Tschechischen Republik rüber gefahren hat es gab.
Der Zoll sitzt vor allem gerne Trojaner ein auch gegen irgendwie Zigarettenschmuggel im größeren Stil oder so das sind die Fälle von denen wir bisher erfahren haben,
dass sie passieren es ist bei weitem nicht so
dass das nur gegen Mord und Totschlag und Terrorismus ist hatte ich ja auch vor kurzem wieder irgend so ein Papier vom BKA veröffentlicht dass sie selber sagen Ja und sind jetzt
300 Fälle bekannt indem wir das gerne gemacht hätten davon sind die Hälfte Drogen und ein Viertel Eigentums Ziel.
Lohmann heute auch noch die Aussagen organisierte Kriminalität.
Ja das
hätten sie wahrscheinlich dann auch so reingeschrieben denn wenn Sie das als politische Propaganda nutzen was auf den Dokumenten von damals eckwirt sich draufstellt dann hätte ich schon erwartet dass sie das größtmögliche geschützt rausholen aber das Wort o.k.
Ist in diesem Zusammenhang nicht gefallen ich weiß nicht es gibt diverseste Drogendelikte von.
Ein bisschen fast leeres Tütchen mit Gras kriegst du in manchen Bundesländern schon Stress und kommst du über Nacht in die Wache Wache und den anderen bist du irgendwie mit 20 Gramm Gras Easy manchmal wird sie abgenommen aber du kriegst noch nicht meine Idee Behandlung oder so,
aber tatsächlich das fängt von,
ganz unten an natürlich gibt geht das dann bisschen zu AOK und kiloweise und mit über Grenzen und so aber das ist aus der,
Übersicht auf die Zahlen die wir haben bisher nicht erkenntlich was was ist und außerdem selbst wenn das OK und Drogen ist damit haben sie uns das im Bundestag nicht verkauft da hieß es immer Mord und Totschlag und der Terror.
Und genauso wie eine normale Telekommunikationsüberwachung vor allem wegen Drogendelikten und Betrugsdelikten und dann irgendwann mal einen Bruch und sowas eingesetzt wird,
wenn das ist meine These und bisher fühle ich mich relativ zuversichtlich dass sie mir die Zahlen recht geben werden vor allen eben bei solchen Delikten eingesetzt dann
bestimmt auch irgendwann mal bei Terror oder so keine Ahnung ob die bei Amri oder sowas auch mal einen Trojaner eingesetzt hätten haben eine Frage die interessiert mich habe ich aber noch keine Antwort zu bekommen
noch sehen wir das nicht aber wir müssen davon ausgehen,
das meiste ist das von dem wir warnen alles schweren Straftaten die so ermittelt werden wie also wendete früher wurden Telefon abgehört TKÜ gemacht,
heute kann ein Trojaner eingesetzt werden und dann ist eine Frage von auf Kosten Nutzen Aufwand wie highprofi ist ja völlig neben Landi und jetzt nicht jeden irgendwie Jugendlichen Kiefer damit zumindest würde ich eindringlich hoffen dass das so nicht passiert.
Aber dazu können die,
eingesetzt werden ja und eingefahren sie auch noch die öfters sie das Einsetzen des Duero könnte der Club seine Hände,
auf sonst Hempel bekommen und das Ding irgendwie wiederhole Löhr-Center Nieren und gucken ob das wirklich nur kann das Canvas das Gesetz erlaubt oder dann sogar in
Anti Virensignaturen Programme einpflegen lassen und quasi erkennen lassen oder so ist ja auch ein ewiges Wettrennen die meisten,
Malware Programme Stufen ja auch Staatstrojaner als Malware ein denn ob das jetzt in Deutschland gegen,
selbst wenn es irgendeinen lass es im Ort sein oder so eingesetzt wäre genau dasselbe Ding wird eben in der Türkei oder in Äthiopien eingesetzt und Malware ist Software die gegen,
dir,
Besitzerin das Gerät Gerät gegen deren konzent eingesetzt wird deswegen bist du auch der Begriff Staatstrojaner so passen das ist ein Trojaner vom Staat denn er tut Dinge die der Besitzer nicht weiß und nicht beabsichtigt,
auch wenn sich die betroffenen Behörden gegen den Begriff werden nein das ist im Endeffekt nur eine Fortführung der Telekommunikationsüberwachung mit anderen Mitteln.
Das gar kein Frühjahr das ist ein schönes Pony auf.
Jena Stadtsportbundes Pony dünner.
Was ist denn deine Wahrnehmung welche Infrastrukturen konkret angegangen werden also wir wissen alle.
Es gibt da auch eine eine gewisse Asymmetrie sowohl was die Verbreitung von Technologien betrifft als auch die angreift
barkeit die klassischen
Desktop Systeme und Server Infrastrukturen sind sicherlich in einem höheren Maße angreifbar weil sie sehr viel mehr Angriffsfläche haben und eben die großen Betriebssysteme in der Regel auch ganz andere Zahl ganz andere Sicherheit,
müssen schlechtere Sicherheit haben.
Im Vergleich zu den Smartphones die aber dann auch eben immer interessanter werden für die Behörden weil sich natürlich dadrauf auch noch viele relevante Informationen befinden Kommunikation Kontakte zitter.
Auch hier haben leider keine Daten aber von allem was ich so höre wird das,
politisch vor allen damit begründet mit der allgegenwärtigen Verschlüsselungen also gerade die messenger sind den im Turnen aufgehört die halt spätestens seit Noten und Sigmund auch schon vorher per Default end-to-end Verschlüsselung haben wo sie tatsächlich nicht mehr so einfach ankommen abgesehen davon
das komische
guten tag Dystopie nicht stimmt weil noch nie hatten so viel ist sie so viele Daten wie heute mit Funktion erfrage Bewegungsdaten und so weiter und so fort Metadaten wo ich glaub Liebe besser meta-data aber sie wollen tatsächlich vor allem an
allgegenwärtiges WhatsApp Run und so und da sind auch gerade die
Quellen TKÜ Trojaner drauf ausgelegt wir haben gelacht dass der erste Ärzte ist diese
Trojaner koenig.de Trojaner den das BKA entwickelt hat nur Skype auf Windows konnte aber natürlich haben sie nachgezogen und dann jetzt irgendwas was wohl auch gegen die gängigen Messenger Apps auf den gängigen mobil
Geräten funktionieren soll Ops in der Praxis funktioniert hatten wir hat es noch nicht in der Hand wissen wir nicht
S4 Mutmaßung tatsächlich gibt's da einige offene Fragen z.b. beim Lesen des Gesetzes mir aufgefallen,
Trojaner dürfen wir gar nicht nur gegen.
E-Zigarette die sich im Besitz von Verdächtigen befinden sondern auch alte Geräte die von denen genutzt werden eingesetzt werden.
Und jetzt frage ich mich was ist denn mit dem E-Mail-Server wo irgendjemand Verdächtige ist einen Account drauf hat oder also sie sie haben das eigentlich eher so gemeint dass wenn
Partner oder der Nachbar oder Partner in crime auch mal einen den Innengerät gibt worüber sie kommunizieren aber was ist denn jetzt mit,
Infrastruktur Dienstleistungen die von Verdächtigen genutzt werden sind offene.
Ich nutze auch Google.
Ja genau genau.
Nutzung sieht so ziemlich alles mit dein.
Deswegen hat ja deine Regierung lisiecki auch bei da kommen gehackt weil irgendwelche ist unter den Millionen von belgischen Nutzern das bestimmt auch irgendeinen der vielleicht mal in den Kontakt zur irgendjemand hatte der einen Terroristen kennt oder so.
Schaue gerade den Bericht dass das wohl irgendwie ganz weit oben in der britischen Regierung abgesegnet wurde diese Aktion und irgendwie Minuten nachdem dieses Noten Enthüllungen
Karma der gtsq das ganz schnell beendet Hund ist aus dem Belgacom Netzwerk wieder raus ja
ist eine gute Frage die ich vielen schlauen juristenstelle und noch keine abschließende Antwort habe aber da arbeiten auch Leute dran können dürfen Behörden auch
Infrastruktur wie Troja E-Mail-Anbieter oder was auch immer Webseiten.
Angreifen.
Was sie technisch haben wissen wir nicht so ganz genau dass die eigene Entwicklung werden wohl nicht das rechts unten Modell sein aber die haben ja auch finfisher gekauft und finde wieder kann alles also.
Es ist so eine ip-technik das Level an Paranoia geht immer noch Diva.
Man sollte sich nicht sicher fühlen nur weil man jetzt irgendwie in denen das neueste immer geupdatete iPhone oder das irgendwie Android ohne Google oder das irgendwie,
die Linux-Distribution für den Hardcore Nerd hat dass man damit irgendwie unhackbar wäre im Gegenteil gerade,
es ist immer ein eine Abwägung wie viel Ressourcen wenden Sie auf unten diese finfisher Suttner entwickelte München habe ich auch noch mit besucht habe ich auch gleich wieder rausgehauen wurde.
Die sind da sächlich relativ weit vorne in der internationalen Entwicklung es gibt drei große Buden die bekannt sind hacking Team Italien,
finfisher aus Deutschland und nSo group aus Israel und das sind wohl die großen Drei von staatstrojanern auf der ganzen Welt und.
Von finfisher darf eben auch die das Bundeskriminalamt und jetzt mittlerweile auch ganz normale Strafverfolgungsbehörden einsetzen und das kann viel,
da würde ich mich mit einem iPhone wischen nicht davon ausgehen die können das eh nicht.
Leipzig immer wenn ich darüber schreibe sofort in den Kommentaren die Frage wie kommen die denn auf mein Gerät da habe ich auch das auf der Dörr.
Wäre jetzt auch meine nächste Frage gewesen.
Das habe ich habe ich aber auf der To-Do-Liste ich bin da auch schon lange drin im recherchieren ich will das nur lieber ordentlich machen als eine schnell einfach hin rotzen.
Die ganz klassische Weg ist mit physischen Zugriff wenn sie dein Zielgerät in der Hand haben.
Was passiert an passieren bei Grenzkontrollen oder Personenkontrollen also ist so ist auch ich krieg das nicht mehr ganz genau zusammen aber ich glaube der,
Trojaner in Bayern Damen mit dem Anabolika Typen der Digitas Trojaner der kam auf.
Entweder bei einer Trance oder Personenkontrolle auf sein Gerät oder und das ist die andere Möglichkeit sie können auch einfach nachts mal deine Wohnung betreten,
quasi mit sowas ähnliches wie einen Durchsuchungsbeschluss in Firma oder in die Wohnung gehen aber da halt nicht unmittelbar was mitnehmen außer es gibt immer drei Zufallsfunde aber das ist noch eine andere juristische Frage,
aber auch einfach mal sich,
paar Stunden an dem Gerät zu schaffen machen und bei Trojaner denken wir immer an das rechts unten Modell und die müssen irgendwie Zero-Day-Exploit und root-Rechte und so,
manchmal reicht auch so einen Scheiß USB Keylogger Dings und damit haben sie auch die pathways vom login und von dem Konto die weiß und alle eingegebenen Dinge haben genug Informationen um die Kiste danach mitzunehmen und zu entschlüsseln,
also,
von allem was ich höre ist das mit dem physischen Zugriff entweder irgendeine Art Kontrolle oder auch noch wohnungsbetretung wie sie das nennen das einfachste was wohl am häufigsten,
gemacht wird es am wenigsten Aufwand und auch am sichersten und das muss irgendwie nicht von Remote.
Mit auf gut Glück gemacht werden sondern kann auch vor Ort probiert werden.
Wenn auch es nicht in allen Bundesländern bisher legalist Wohnungen zu betreten um Staatstrojaner auf zwei Spielen gibt das gesetzliche Forderung dass das für alle LKA es erlaubt werden soll das ist unter anderem Teil dieser ganzen Polizeigesetze.
Und wir reden zu viel von Zero days dann irgendwie was hat das LKA hat Berlin hat letzte Woche eine Ausschreibung für,
also ID Security-Leute um im Einsatz essklang auf seiner staatstrojanern die haben irgendwie Leute gesucht die sich mit Portscans und sowas auskennen um irgendwie nächstes noch genannt footprinting,
um irgendwie zu gucken welche Geräte welche Leute nutzen um dann auf der Datenbasis zu entscheiden wie wir an die Geräte am besten rankommen das klingt alles so wie,
ja wie man halt Kisten im Internet aufmacht.
Natürlich verboten deswegen hat das nie jemand gemacht aber vielleicht du bist ja unter den Zuhörern Leute Suppen die dann aus der eigenen Erfahrung ableiten ja so oder so ähnlich könnte das der Staat machen aber der hat natürlich noch ganz andere Möglichkeiten als natürlich.
Könnten die das theoretisch auch so machen aber ich habe jetzt mit einem Juristen gesprochen und da gibt fällt demnächst auch mal einen paper in einer renommierten Publikation raus aber es ist noch nicht fertig.
Ob es den Behörden erlaubt ist.
Phishing-Mails oder fishing Kommunikation zu verschicken und dabei andere Institutionen zu im Person ihren also sich als andere auszugeben.
Ist es legal entweder sich als Telekom auszugeben oder die Telekom dazu zu verpflichten einem Anschlussinhaber,
eine SMS zu schreiben mit hier unser Netzwerk wird go Upgrader du brauchst eine neue APN oder wie auch immer das heißt und lade dir mal diese diese App hier runter auf dein Gerät wir wissen ja auch welche,
welches System du hast.
Kollegin Italien hat rausgefunden in Italien ist das legal haben noch keine noch keine Fälle gefunden wo es passiert ist aber Dokument geht daraus hervor wie viel die Telekom Behörden dazu,
an Kohle verlangen und das ist gesetzlich auch sein kann das eben Telekommunikationsanbieter zur Mitwirkung verpflichtet werden können in irgendeiner Form,
oder nenne voriges BKA fängt an E-Mail zu verschicken in deinen menschliches man Einwohnermeldeamt Termin
probiert mussten ohne online in Termin klicken kriegst dann irgendwann eine mail was ist wenn du dann dort mir gepimpte mehr als toder immer mehr digitale Kommunikation mit Behörden ich denk mein Elster.
Alle Leute müssen ihre Steuererklärung digital machen also es geht jetzt nicht jeder zum Laden und holt sich eine CD und schiebt das irgendwie in sein Gerät aber auch dieses,
diese online Web-Plattform die sie da haben.
Sie einstecken extrem für Soßen rein damit das Ding möglichst vertrauenserweckend ist.
Und dann irgendwann gibt's den Punkt wo das BKA sagt ja ja ja aber im Ausnahmefall wenn es wirklich wichtig ist möchten wir uns als Elster ausgeben und mit Leuten kommunizieren so kommunizieren dass es sich von unserer Mail einen Trojaner eingefangen.
Das ist gerade eine rechtliche Frage an der Klärung ich arbeite es sieht wohl danach aus als ob die Behörden das dürfen.
Und das wäre natürlich immensa Vertrauensverlust das sind Methoden die also klar gibt's Social Engineering und Fischingen und so aber die so ganz normale Internet kriminelle nicht einfach mal so nutzen können aber der Staat wenn er es macht dann schon.
Unten die rechts unten Tipi Lösung ist natürlich.
Zum Produkt Finn fly ESP das ist eins der vielen Produkte aus der Bandbreite aus der Produktpalette von finfisher
irgendwie ein kleiner Server kommt in das Netz von was auch immer Internetanbieter ob das jetzt irgendwie mobil oder DSL oder Kabel oder was auch immer ist,
und unser Ziel User lädt gerade eine Software runter eine apk eine Echse einer was auch immer da draußen so gibt ja dann pimpen würde ich halt mal und hängen da noch was dran.
ITunes Updates hat finfisher sogar selber damit geworben dass sie sich genau an die ihren hängen können gab es vor kurzem auch,
Forschung jetzt im Winter dass das in der Türkei genauso passiert ist das damit so deep Packet Inspection Boxen genauso Leute mit Starts Wörtern identifiziert wurden also jetzt Opa herunter oder in VLC oder so
kommt ne gepimpte Version zu dir also.
Das Ding von ich nutze irgendwie nur Tales oder irgendwie nur das neueste iOS.
Ja man kann die Kosten möglichst in die Höhe treiben und die Wahrscheinlichkeit relativ niedrig und ist potentiellen Angreifern egal ob
der Staat oder anderen Kriminellen das möglichst schwermachen,
aber ab einem bestimmten fettlevel wird's einfach sehr schwer sich ging alles abzusichern und jetzt haben noch nicht mal davon geredet irgendwie bei Auszug irgendwie Flächen cold
nuttx irgendwie RAM Riegel mit den cryptokeys da drinnen auszulesen und so das gibt's ja auch alles.
Da wo bei meiner Tür auch bei den Herstellern zunehmendem Maße gegen Aufrüstung auch beobachtet.
Köln Arcaden.
Bluetooth sich da besonders hervor auch gerade was so Firmware und so weiter betrifft so dieses ganze mit ich drück meine Taste und Gutmann von woanders und so das ist da mittlerweile auch,
alles verhinderbar muss man natürlich sehen wie resilient dieses Thema dann unterm Strich wirklich sind aber hierhammer ist dann halt
wirklich noch mit einer Aufrüstung der aufrechten zu tun ist zumindest ist es ja auch die offizielle Doktrin von Apple an der Stelle eben möglichst.
Angreifbar zu sein Leben mit der Aussage die Privatsphäre zu schützen
jetzt natürlich die Frage wie lange können Sie das noch aufrechterhalten Nadja 1:56 Sendung auch schon mal den nächsten Fallout schon betrachtet das Wifi weiß jetzt eben schon danach getrachtet wird hier
hier die alte Geschichte vom legalen Vektor Zugang wieder auszugraben und Hersteller von Technologie wenn sie überhaupt was verkaufen wollen dazu zu Pflicht zu verpflichten
ondemand eben Hintertürchen aufzumachen um daneben das Überwachen zu ermöglichen,
was tut man jetzt sagen okay das ist jetzt vielleicht auch so ein Einsehen von mit dieser ganzen Trojaner Geschichte und benutzen Sicherheitslücken aus oder.
Haben ebenso andere kriminelle Praktiken am Start und mein Passwort da ranzukommen.
Das skaliert irgendwie alles nicht das bringt uns nur mehr Ärger warum nicht einfach alle dazu verpflichten Hintertürchen aufzumachen die auf unseren Markt wollen und fertig ist die Laube.
Ja bis Hintertüren ist natürlich eine Möglichkeit aber das sagen immer alle nein nein wollen wir nicht Sicherheit trotz voll durch Verschlüsselung und Sicherheit trotz Verschlüsselung aber
mein vor 10 Jahren heißt paranoid geklungen und jetzt ging es paranoid aber vor 5 Jahren nicht.
Was ist wenn die NSA einfach mal abgehackte und sich irgendwie in die Hard und Software Design Einheit wie sie es bei RSA Security gemacht haben mit ihren Zufallsgenerator der dann
nur so mittel guten Zufall ausgespuckt hat und auf einmal war die Gruppe im Arsch und Standards auf ATF Ebene,
was war aber der auch elliptic curve Zufallsgenerator der irgendwie schon immer ein bisschen komisch roch aber dann erst mit den Snowden Enthüllungen feststand oh ja
wir haben uns wirklich über den Tisch gezogen die haben da ihre eigene Backdoor drin von dir die Hersteller das noch nicht mal wissen es ist sogar ein offener Standard wir können sogar alle Akademiker
drauf gucken und vielleicht sogar finden wenn sie wirklich gut sind aber es muss ja nicht nur die Verpflichtungen sein meines klingt
paranoid mittlerweile aber vor 5 Jahren Slooten da haben wir das an jeden zweiten Wochentag eine neue Enthüllung genau dieser Größenordnung gelesen.
Nur weil man paranoid war heißt das noch lange nicht dass sie dich doch in Deinem Herzen ja also diese Batterie wir kriegen nichts.
Die haben wir ja schon längst.
Real in Deutsch.
Also ist also die Debatte ob.
Der BND jetzt anfängt Apple zu hacken das weiß ich nicht so ganz genau die NSA und Ciesielski US und die Russen Chinesen Israelis Nummern ganz anderes Level,
aber an auch in Deutschland haben wir ja schon,
lange die Debatte eben mit diesem komischen Mantra Sicherheit durch Verschlüsselung und Sicherheit trotz Verschlüsselungen der Staatstrojaner ist ja eine Ausprägung davon aber gerade passieren im Innenministerium.
Wenn sie denn nicht nur in der Tagespolitik komische Dinge tun sondern auch auf Arbeitsgruppen Ebenen ein Papier zum,
Richtlinien zum Umgang mit Schwachstellen was sie denn tun wenn deutsche staatliche Behörden von Schwachstellen erfahren unter welchen Voraussetzungen sie das den Herstellern
melden damit die für alle Wiki fixed werden oder unter welchen natürlich immer noch einen ganz wichtigen und eng begrenzten und begründeten Ausnahmefällen Sie dann das eventuell für sich nutzen können ohne das den Herstellern zu sagen,
dann viele verschiedene Richtung jeder jedes Produkt hat immer Lücken und die klare Ansage der Sicherheitspolitiker ist.
Wir wollen ja ausnutzen weil wir müssen die Bad Guys fangen und nur so geht das damit ihren Position.
Die Debatte haben wir schon längst und es wird wichtig weiter laut weiter zu beobachten laut zu sein und zu sagen so geht's nicht der Preis.
Dafür ist viel zu hoch ihr macht ihr produziert viel mehr Unsicherheit als Sicherheit dir damit Gewinn zu einem zu meinem Wettrennen Venice 192 Staaten die wir da draußen haben jeder hat noch irgendwie eine Polizei und Geheimdienst oder so wenn jetzt alle anfangen,
jeweils oder ist diese finden Lücken für sich auszunutzen ich meine das ist dann in race to the bottom der gewinnt keiner mehr in der IT security wir sollten aber irgendwie die IT Sicherheit so hoch wie möglich für alle nehmen,
das ist ja das Problem auch an dem,
internationalen Märkten für Sony Schwachstellen die daneben irgendwie an die Höchstbietenden also NSA oder die Staatstrojaner Boden gehen,
normalerweise sollten eben lügen nicht verkauft oder ausgenutzt sondern die Hersteller gemeldet werden und wenn jetzt irgendwie auch das BSI anfällt,
wann fängt im Ausnahmefall mal nicht so genau hin zu gucken was denn jetzt das BKA macht mit der Lücke die man eventuell nächste Woche an den Hersteller meldet.
Das ist halt eine große Gefahr das bringt uns vielmehr IT Unsicherheit alles Unsinn öffentliche Sicherheit irgendwie gewinnen könnte.
Durch ein paar Gefangene Drogendealer.
Nicht gut.
Gut nicht gut genau nicht gut aber ja.
Abriss Trojaner übrigens ich habe.
Das muss man erstmal zu Ende bringen.
Noch mal einen noch so ein Rundumschlag zu Trojanern gemacht mit dem Datenschutz Podcast heißt ja von Claudia aus Wien und ich werde darüber auch auf der,
privacy breach noch mal ein Vortrag halten.
Dann Schutz bot.
Ja der ist noch nicht online die hatten vor mehreren Wochen genau der vor während Wochen aufgenommen und der kommt dann glaube ich dämlich.
Okay wir verlinken einfach mal hier auf die Podcast Webseite genau gut andre würde sagen das bringt uns jetzt zu den Terminen.
Soja und es ist ja gerade noch privacy Weg in Berlin das Fliegen jetzt hiermit das ist Netzpolitik an und läuft noch ein bisschen dieses Wochenende endet das dann mit der Pfiff Korn die hat mir hier schon
angesprochen wäre jetzt ganz flink beim nachhören dieser Sendung ist noch kurzer Hinweis dass es
heute und morgen also am 27 und 28 September noch die digital development die Baits gibt in Kooperation mit der Gesellschaft für Informatik TU Berlin im weizenbaum-institut
für die vernetzte Gesellschaft und Konnektiv und ja da geht's um die Frage ob Deutschland ein digitales Entwicklungsland ist Höhe was für eine Frage,
wir haben uns dazu Expert nach Brasilien wo an der Hund China eingeladen das ist natürlich sehr nett Manu Andernach fragen wie du das funktionieren kann bist du der mit dem digitalen Fortschritt weil essen wir halt noch nicht so viel,
gib mir Informationen unter ddd.dda.dk Name kostenlos.
Kleine Korrektur Depressivität gestern angefangen und die geht bis Dienstag zum netzpolitische Name der Liege gestern er sie weiß und die Netzpolitik Konferenz war noch nicht Teil der brexit.
Achso okay gut es wäre jetzt meine Wahrnehmung gewesen aber gut dann ist es halt so
weiterhin auch an diesem Wochenende noch 21 September in Stuttgart gibt es eine cryptoparty in der Stadtbibliothek Stuttgart
veranstaltet von CCC Stuttgart geht um 14 Uhr los und gib Kekse und Mate und alles ca
Link dazu findet ihr in den Shownotes dann am 9. November 2018 gibt's die night of Open knowledge
schön abgekürzt mit NUK.
Nach dem großen Erfolg der Med Anouk in den vergangenen Jahren veranstalten Studierende der Uni Lübeck gemeinsam mit dem chaotikum,
am 9. November wieder einen lockeren Abend zum Austausch von Wissen eben die night of Open knowledge bis zum 3. Oktober können sogar noch
Vorträge Workshops und Lightning Talks eingereicht werden Meter nuk.de Slash 2018 dann
verweisen wir noch ein wenig mehr in die Zukunft 3. Oktober gibt's noch mal eine Demonstration gegen das polizeiaufgabengesetz in München was er ein schon beschlossen ist aber hier fleißig,
weiter demonstriert & Rücknahme gefordert weil geht ja mal gar nicht und der demnächst Landtagswahlen in Bayern da kann man schon mal ein bisschen rumoren auch dazu an mir noch einen,
linke ich denk mal das wird mal wieder an im Zentrum der Stadt stattfinden.
Odeonsplatz steht hier so gut kenne ich mich in München auch nicht aus gemeinsam gegen die Politik der Angst.
Odeonsplatz ok jetzt mal was durch Marienplatz okay holt dir.
Soviel zu kommst aus nächsten Mittwoch ein Feiertag Kranz und Eier reunification.
Der Monat ist ja schon fast zu Ende ich habe das fast übersehen ja ok so aber dann hat sie dich noch ein wenig mehr in der Zukunft in knappen im Monat,
gibt's nämlich einerseits unser siebenjähriges Existenz Jubiläum hiervon Logbuch Netzpolitik wo es gar nicht so einen großen Tanz rausmachen wollen es trifft sich nur gerade vom Datum her den am 27 October wenn wir dann auf der
eigentlich ein privacy wkda die angefangen hat damit nämlich die in Wien sein wenn ihr Lust habt dabei zu sein könnt ihr
dort auflaufen privacy Wiki.
Jetzt habe ich Volkskundemuseum in Wien ist das wenn ich mich jetzt nicht komplett vertan habe mit all diesen ganzen Begriffen die um mich herum,
fegen und.
Dabei könnt ihr sein und das ganze geht los um 18 Uhr.
Du bist auch sein auf der Paris ewig Thomas wird da sein also könnt ihr mal so hier die Logbuch Netzpolitik All Stars treffen.
Bin schon so oft nach Berlin kommt müssen wir auch immer wie ein besuchen.
Oder auch einfach nur dasitzen und dem ganzen lauschen und danach mit uns ein Bierchen Lüften oder was heißt das dazu einfällt.
Wie geht den Ausfall geburtstag.
Mal gucken ja.
Das war's bis Hagen andre.
Soweit eine Woche ohne allzu viele nennen was heißt da eigenes Gesicht genug passiert aber ohne viele tagesaktuelle News wir haben uns doch irgendwie mit.
Konferenz Aufgabe Netzpolitik Trojaner Zoe Ameisenmittel längerfristige Themen genommen aber letzte Woche ich war ja gerade noch den mit Thomas auch über die ganze ganze BVT geheimdienstaffäre auch mal so,
ein Rückblick über eine längere Zeit was dann passiert ist wenn der Podcast die oft ist ja viel von den News der letzten Woche dominiert wird.
Nächste Woche wieder.
Suche genau diese Woche kommt auch noch mal Thomas wieder ins Spiel dann wenn man dann auch noch mal die Entwicklung aufgreifen und dann irgendwann auch mal wieder mit Linus,
schöne Grüße an Linus an dieser Stelle an der ihr sicherlich interessiert zugehört hat uns natürlich auch,
alle anderen Hörer die auch mal sehr interessiert zu hören ihr dürft kommentieren bei uns Bock gerne alles aufgreifen was ihr möchtet und damit machen wir jetzt hier ein Schlusspunkt solange Tschüss bis bald.